Witaj ponownie w obliczeniach kwantowych w praktyce. Ten odcinek skupi się na pierwszym i często najtrudniejszym
kroku w definiowaniu programu kwantowego: mapowaniu ogólnego problemu na circuit, który może działać na komputerze kwantowym.
Ten krok opisuje, jak użytkownik zaczynający od danego problemu obliczeniowego
może go przetłumaczyć, żeby komputer kwantowy mógł go zrozumieć.
W poprzednich lekcjach tej serii – lekcjach drugiej i trzeciej – omówiliśmy, że etap mapowania jest pierwszym krokiem spośród
czterech w ramach Qiskit patterns. Z tych lekcji możesz pamiętać, że naszym celem było przetłumaczenie
lub przepisanie problemu obliczeniowego na funkcję kosztową lub wartość oczekiwaną,
którą możemy ewaluować za pomocą komputera kwantowego.
W lekcji trzeciej omówiliśmy jeden konkretny przykład z max cut – problemem,
który jest obliczeniowo trudny i powszechnie spotykany w optymalizacji kombinatorycznej.
W tamtym przykładzie przeszliśmy przez kilka kroków, żeby przekształcić początkowy graf w problem natywny dla kwantowego. Przekształciliśmy
problem znajdowania maksymalnej liczby cięć w grafie w funkcję kosztową, następnie przepisaliśmy tę funkcję kosztową
jako Hamiltonian i przygotowaliśmy próbny stan kwantowy, którego stan podstawowy
odpowiada max cut. Na koniec skonstruowaliśmy quantum circuit reprezentujący próbny stan kwantowy będący przedmiotem
zainteresowania, a następnie dodaliśmy konkretne bramki, żeby pozwolić stanowi ewoluować w czasie. Ta sekwencja kroków to to, co
nazywamy mapowaniem. I na wysokim poziomie ta procedura jest ogólna dla wielu innych zastosowań, takich jak chemia kwantowa
i symulacja kwantowa. Teraz nie ma co ukrywać, że mapowanie może być trudne. Nie ma
strategii pasującej do wszystkich problemów, więc może to być onieśmielające. Dzisiaj wyróżnię
kilka reprezentatywnych przykładów różnych problemów i opiszę, jak były mapowane w każdym przypadku. Szybko
przypomnę, czego dowiedzieliśmy się o problemach grafowych jak te używane w Max Cut, i spędzę resztę wykładu skupiając się
na tym, jak mapować problemy, które pojawiają się w naturze, takie jak problemy struktury molekularnej w biologii, problemy struktury
elektronowej w chemii i symulacja kwantowych teorii pola w fizyce wysokich energii.
Ale zanim spędzimy większość czasu w tym odcinku patrząc na przykładowe problemy z literatury, chcę dać ci
ogólny przegląd głównych rzeczy, które chcemy osiągnąć i wziąć pod uwagę przy mapowaniu problemu. Jest
kilka rzeczy do rozważenia dla każdego rodzaju problemu obliczeniowego, który będzie musiał być przetłumaczony na quantum circuit.
Po pierwsze, możesz potrzebować uprościć problem, żeby uczynić go wykonalnym. To jest coś powszechnego w większości dyscyplin naukowych.
Nie jest to unikalne dla obliczeń kwantowych. Jeśli kiedykolwiek słyszałeś wyrażenie „załóż sferyczną krowę",
nawiązuje ono do faktu, że często trudno jest opisać układ dokładnie tak, jak wygląda. Ale
zamiast tego możemy robić rozsądne uproszczenia, które wciąż mogą prowadzić do pomocnych rozwiązań.
Kilka przykładów tego, jak moglibyśmy to zrobić w obliczeniach kwantowych: ograniczyć rozmiar lub głębokość circuit, wybierając
sprzętowo wydajne ansatze, lub obcinać złożone ewolucje czasowe, albo zaniedbywać
człony hamiltonianowe, które mało przyczyniają się do końcowej energii stanu kwantowego.
Następna kwestia, którą chcę poruszyć, to to, że będziesz musiał pomyśleć o napisaniu problemu w taki sposób, żeby komputer kwantowy mógł go zrozumieć.
Często wiąże się to z zadaniem sobie tych trzech pytań. Pierwsze: co będą reprezentować nasze qubity
w tym modelu? Drugie: czy nasz problem jest ciągły? Ponieważ komputery kwantowe są cyfrowe, będziesz musiał
znaleźć sposób na dyskretyzację problemu. I trzecie, ostatnie: czy topologia problemu jest zgodna z topologią
sprzętu? Jeśli tak, świetnie. Ale jeśli nie, możemy potrzebować zaimplementować kilka trików, żeby to działało. Więc zajmijmy się
tym pierwszym pytaniem. Myślę, że jest ono w samym sercu wszystkich trudności ze zrozumieniem mapowania, zwłaszcza jako
nowego konceptu. Co może reprezentować qubit?
Qubity mogą być używane do reprezentowania wielu rzeczy. Pierwsza i najprościej moim zdaniem to węzeł na grafie. Grafy są
używane do pokazywania łączności i wielu różnych typów problemów matematycznych, a węzły są fundamentalnym elementem reprezentującym punkt
lub encję w sieci. W zależności od tego, co reprezentuje cała sieć, może to być miasto, osoba lub
ferromagnes w sieci krystalicznej. Qubity mogą być też używane do reprezentowania bozonów i fermionów. Choć uprzedzam,
że jeden qubit nie równa się dokładnie jednemu bozonowi lub jednemu fermionowi. To jest nieco
trudniejsze i zajmę się tym wkrótce, ale ogólnie łańcuch spinów podlegający pewnym statystykom to
coś, co można łatwo przetłumaczyć na architekturę qubitową.
Teraz wchodzimy w przykłady nieco bardziej skomplikowane. W tych modelach nie ma już sensu mówić o
pojedynczym qubicie.
Zamiast tego potrzebujemy ich grup, żeby tworzyć coś fizycznego. Na przykład,
grupa qubitów reprezentowana tutaj na topologii heavy hexagonal może być używana do reprezentowania geometrycznych lokalizacji aminokwasów
lub łańcuchów polimerowych. Innym przykładem jest symulacja rozpraszania hadronów
w modelach fizyki wysokich energii, co można zrobić symulując ewolucję czasową kwantowego pakietu fal hadronowych. W tym przypadku
rejestr qubitów może być używany do kodowania różnych stanów pola kwantowego – próżniowego stanu tego pola lub
pakietu fal rozchodzącego się na tym próżniowym tle.
Chcę też zaznaczyć, że mapowanie problemu na komputer kwantowy ma odrębne kroki: pierwszy to mapowanie
stanów na qubity i circuits, a drugi to mapowanie funkcji kosztowej lub wartości oczekiwanej
kwantowych obserwowalnych i operatorów. Zobaczymy, jak są one obsługiwane w konkretnych przykładach. Ale
w tym momencie mówiliśmy wystarczająco abstrakcyjnie o wyzwaniu, które przed nami stoi.
Przyjrzyjmy się teraz szczegółowo tym przykładom.
Zacznijmy od pierwszego przykładu. Moim zdaniem jednym z najłatwiejszych problemów mapowania jest ten, który już
w pewnym stopniu omówiliśmy – przykład max cut. W tamtym problemie mapowanie było dla nas całkiem proste, bo jeden qubit
WEBVTT
równał jednemu węzłowi na naszym grafie. Używanie węzłów na grafie jest bardzo intuicyjne i to jest
korzystne, bo odpowiada wielu zastosowaniom. Wiele razy, gdy chcesz modelować coś, co odpowiada
serii węzłów połączonych ze sobą, jeśli grupowania są binarne jak zero lub jeden, albo uwzględniony i nieuwzględniony w
zbiorze, możesz po prostu i naturalnie mapować te węzły na bity lub qubity.
W tym przykładzie, a nawet w tym, który skalowaliśmy do 100 qubitów w odcinku 3, połączalność grafu
już pasowała do topologii naszego nadprzewodzącego sprzętu. Więc nie musieliśmy się tym też martwić. Jednak tak nie jest zawsze.
I jeśli masz bardziej skomplikowany lub bardziej połączony graf niż przykłady, które omówiliśmy do tej pory, będziesz musiał
zaimplementować bramki swap. Ale to jest obsługiwane na drugim etapie Qiskit patterns, który dotyczy
transpilacji. Inną częścią problemu max cut, która czyni go tak poręcznym, jest to, że
już wiemy, jak wyrazić funkcję kosztową jako Hamiltonian, używając formułowania Ising.
Przypomnij sobie, że w obliczeniach kwantowych i wariacyjnych algorytmach kwantowych, hamiltonianowa funkcja kosztowa to funkcja,
która koduje optymalne rozwiązanie problemu w stanie podstawowym Hamiltonianu.
Żeby skonstruować Hamiltonian kosztowy, mogliśmy użyć klasy sparse poly op w Qiskit, żeby określić
połączalność naszego grafu, a etap mapowania do operatorów kwantowych jest gotowy. A quantum circuit był
po prostu ansatzem QAOA. Jeśli to nie dzwoni dzwonkiem, wróć do odcinka 3, gdzie dokładnie przez to
przechodzimy. Teraz nieznacznie podnieśmy poprzeczkę trudności. Następnie przyjrzymy się
przykładowi modelowanemu w artykule zatytułowanym „Resource Efficient Quantum Algorithm for Protein Folding" napisanym przez
IBM we współpracy z University of New South Wales. Trochę biochemicznego tła: białka to
makrocząsteczki złożone z długich łańcuchów aminokwasów. Te długie łańcuchy składają się
w złożone struktury, które pełnią różnorodne funkcje biologiczne.
Określanie struktury białka w trójwymiarowej przestrzeni i rozumienie relacji między
strukturą a funkcją należy do najtrudniejszych problemów we współczesnej biochemii.
Białka składają się w użyteczne struktury ze względu na oddziaływania między samymi aminokwasami.
W miarę jak struktura skręca się i składa, aminokwasy odległe od siebie w łańcuchu mogą znajdować się blisko
siebie nawzajem i silnie oddziaływać. Musimy uzyskać Hamiltonian opisujący wszystkie te oddziaływania między aminokwasami,
jeśli chcemy przewidzieć, jaka końcowa struktura minimalizuje energię. Skupimy się tutaj na łańcuchach aminokwasów i
na tym, jak mogą być modelowane na komputerze kwantowym, a następnie jak możemy uzyskać odległości między aminokwasami do
obliczenia energii oddziaływania.
Dzięki temu faktycznie zbierzemy wszystkie niezbędne wkłady do Hamiltonianu, żeby móc go symulować
na komputerze kwantowym. W rzeczywistych białkach aminokwasy mogą zajmować ciągły zakres możliwych lokalizacji.
Jednak użyjemy tutaj uproszczenia i ograniczymy je do modelu kratowego, gdzie każdy aminokwas
zajmuje punkt na siatce. Tutaj autorzy użyli sieci czworościennej.
Szybka uwaga: tutaj kodujemy kierunek krawędzi, a nie same węzły jak w problemie max cut.
Każdy qubit reprezentuje możliwą jednoetapową ścieżkę wzdłuż siatki czworościennej. Pamiętaj, że sąsiednie miejsca zostały
oznaczone na tym diagramie jako A lub B ze względu na ich różną orientację w sieci.
Łańcuch białkowy jest reprezentowany jako seria skrętów lub kierunków na tej
sieci. Każdy skręt między aminokwasami może być w jednym z czterech kierunków
odpowiadających krawędziom czworościanu.
Te cztery możliwe skręty są kodowane przy użyciu czterech qubitów.
Brzmi to nieco trudno, więc przyjrzyjmy się temu przykładowi trochę głębiej.
Umieśćmy nasz pierwszy aminokwas w tym punkcie siatki czworościennej. Kierunek do pierwszego
następnego aminokwasu jest dowolny, bo układ zawsze można po prostu obrócić, żeby ta krawędź wskazywała
w dowolnym kierunku. Więc umieśćmy nasz drugi aminokwas tutaj. Nie jest to tak
łatwo zobaczyć, ale ścieżka od drugiego do trzeciego jest faktycznie też dowolna. Wszystkie trzy wybory skutkowałyby
posiadaniem dwóch krawędzi z kątem około 109,5°
między nimi. Wybór tej drugiej krawędzi po prostu wyznacza orientację naszego białka w przestrzeni. Więc bez utraty
ogólności możemy wybrać, żeby pierwsze skręty były po prostu 0 0 1 i 0 0 1
0. Przy tych uproszczeniach konfiguracja łańcucha aminokwasów jest po prostu dana tym wyrażeniem.
Do tej pory zmapowaliśmy krawędzie czworościanu na qubity i nasz quantum circuit będzie ansatzem. Teraz musimy
rozważyć, jak zakodować energię problemu w Hamiltoniannie, żeby jego stan podstawowy dał nam optymalny
wzorzec składania. Dla dowolnej danej konfiguracji będzie powiązana energia ze względu na
oddziaływania między samymi aminokwasami. Te oddziaływania są najsilniejsze, gdy dwa aminokwasy są
blisko siebie. Oczywiście aminokwasy sąsiednie w szkielecie łańcucha zawsze będą oddziaływać ze
sobą. Ale ponieważ białko może się skręcać i składać, inne pary aminokwasów
mogą też oddziaływać. Aminokwasy 10 i 20, na przykład, mogą znajdować się na
sąsiednich miejscach po złożeniu białka. Aminokwasy, które są blisko siebie, mają silniejsze
oddziaływania i napędzają proces składania, ale niekoniecznie mają indeksy bliskie sobie
nawzajem. Więc potrzebujemy formuły opisującej odległość D między aminokwasami I i
J, używając informacji zakodowanych na qubitach konfiguracji. W ten sposób możemy
użyć ich odległości separacji, żeby ustalić, jak silnie oddziałują. Jest to nieco skomplikowane,
ale bądź cierpliwy, bo to zgrabny trik. Najpierw wprowadźmy funkcję f_a(i), która wskazuje, czy
WEBVTT
krawędź a jest używana dla skrętu przy aminokwasie i. Tutaj a może przyjmować dowolny
z czterech możliwych kierunków. W świetle powyższego kodowania konfiguracji możemy zapisać te funkcje, a następnie
możemy zdefiniować różnicę liczby skrętów oznaczonych a na siatkach A i B od
indeksu I do indeksu J jako delta N. Dlaczego to robimy? Otóż okazuje się, że
sieć czworościenna ma bardzo użyteczną właściwość. Skupmy się na tym aminokwasie tutaj – nieważne którym,
nazwijmy go aminokwasem E. Chcemy wiedzieć, jak daleko będzie j-ty aminokwas. Mamy jedynie
krawędzie wzdłuż których kroczy szkielet. Zaczynając od I, zauważ, że krok
od centrum wzdłuż określonego typu krawędzi – nazwijmy go a – z tego miejsca siatki A
jest dokładnie przeciwny i jest cofany przez krok wzdłuż krawędzi a z
miejsc B. Więc wielokrotne kroki wzdłuż krawędzi A z dowolnego miejsca siatki A przesuwają
szkielet od aminokwasu E, a kroki wzdłuż krawędzi A z miejsc B
przybliżają. Więc odległość między dwoma aminokwasami I i J wzdłuż krawędzi
którą oznaczymy A, zależy od różnicy kroków wykonanych wzdłuż krawędzi A
z miejsc A i B. Ponieważ A i B naprzemiennie w szkielecie białkowym, jest to uchwycone przez składnik minus 1 do potęgi K. I ten argument stosuje się do innych typów krawędzi
również. Więc odległość między aminokwasami w krokach siatki czworościennej można ostatecznie obliczyć przez to
wyrażenie. Ale jak uzyskujemy Hamiltonian z tego długiego równania na całkowitą odległość między aminokwasami? Otóż
istnieje odpowiedniość jeden do jednego między tymi odległościami w krokach siatki czworościennej a odległością
euklidesową. I widać, że już obliczyłam kilka wyrażeń dla ciebie.
Te odległości mogą być używane do obliczania energii twojej konfiguracji.
W zależności od celu możesz ustalić odległość odcięcia poniżej której uważasz parę za oddziałującą,
lub możesz zrobić coś bardziej skomplikowanego. Może nie być oczywiste, ale faktycznie jesteśmy gotowi z etapem mapowania
przez to. Stany qubitów wskazują skręt, a zbiór skrętów wyznacza
odległość między dowolną parą aminokwasów. Pary różnych gatunków aminokwasów
mają różne oddziaływania – jedne przyciągające, inne odpychające. Jeśli używasz konfiguracji i odległości, żeby
jedynie ustalić, czy znane oddziaływania aminokwasów są włączone czy wyłączone,
ich intensywności są dobrze znane. Nie przeze mnie, ale możesz je wyszukać w tabeli takiej jak ta. Podsumowując, w
tym przykładzie qubity są używane do oznaczania lokalizacji na sieci, które razem tworzą łańcuch aminokwasów.
I symulując, jak się zginają i składają, możemy mieć nadzieję znaleźć lepsze wyniki w badaniach medycznych. Teraz
pominęliśmy, jak obliczyć kilka człony tego Hamiltonianu, bo były hiper specyficzne dla tego problemu. Podczas gdy definiowanie
kierunków na sieci można stosować szerzej.
Teraz, gdy masz ogólny Hamiltonian, zawsze będziesz chciał przetłumaczyć go na operatory pauliowskie, które
są natywne dla komputera kwantowego. O tym będziemy rozmawiać dalej.
Kontynuujmy. Teraz zbadajmy, jak przetłumaczyć układ cząstek subatomowych na operatory pauliowskie. Cząstki subatomowe
są podzielone na dwie kategorie: bozony i fermiony. Bozony
takie jak fotony lub bozon Higgsa podlegają pewnemu zestawowi reguł statystycznych, a fermiony jak elektrony lub neutrina podlegają innym.
Kluczowa różnica między nimi polega na tym, że bozony mogą zajmować ten sam stan. Nie ma limitu, ile
bozonów może być w stanie podstawowym lub jakimkolwiek innym stanie wzbudzonym. Fermiony natomiast są samolubne – wymagają, żeby
każda cząstka miała własny stan kwantowy. Bozony mają też całkowite spiny, a fermiony połówkowe spiny całkowite,
jak spin 1/2 elektronu lub bardziej egzotyczne cząstki o spinie 3/2. Żeby
opisać układ cząstek, potrzebujemy opisu ich energii. Skupmy się na fermionach. Możemy zacząć od
Hamiltonianu zapisanego w kategoriach tzw. operatorów C. Są to zasadniczo obiekty matematyczne, które
odpowiadają tworzeniu lub anihilacji fermionów w stanie układu.
Są często zapisywane jako fi dagger i fi, w notacji, którą nazywamy drugą
kwantyzacją. Teraz fi dagger to operator tworzący fermion w stanie i. Fi to
operator niszczący fermion w stanie i. Ale pamiętaj, że komputery kwantowe zazwyczaj działają w bazie
qubitowej z konkretnymi regułami reprezentowania systemów fermionowych. Nie działają z natury w języku
operatorów fermionowych. Żeby wypełnić tę lukę, musimy zmapować notację drugiej kwantyzacji na operatory pauliowskie, które
naturalnie odpowiadają bramkom kwantowym.
Istnieje kilka takich transformacji dla fermionów. Popularnym wyborem jest transformacja Jordana-Wignera.
Odwzorowania Bravyi-Kitaeva i parzystości są nowszymi dla kodowań fermionowych.
Operacje bozonowe natomiast można transformować, używając transformacji Holsteina-Primakoffa lub bezpośrednio
mapując stany Focka na podbazę dostępnych trybów bozonowych.
Istnieją też inne opcje dla bozonów. Inne kodowania są też aktywnie badane. Ale na razie skupimy się
tylko na transformacji Jordana-Wignera.
Więc dlaczego nie przypisać po prostu jednego qubitu do reprezentowania każdego elektronu? Cóż, nie możemy.
Qubity są rozróżnialne, a elektrony nie. Na przykład możemy łatwo oznaczyć i identyfikować poszczególne qubity na
dowolnym urządzeniu, ale nierozróżnialność elektronów oznacza, że nie możemy ich w ogóle oznaczyć. Musimy faktycznie oznaczać
zamiast tego operatory według zajętych orbitali, jak 1s, 2s i 2p,
zamiast konkretnych elektronów. Tak więc musimy faktycznie oznaczyć operatory według zajętych orbitali, jak 1s
2s i 2p, zamiast oznaczać konkretne elektrony. Więc każdy qubit pełni
WEBVTT
mniej więcej rolę orbitalu w cząsteczce, który jest albo zajęty, albo niezajęty.
Ale to, jak to robimy, jest faktycznie nieco bardziej skomplikowane. Teraz wprowadzamy coś zwanego odwzorowaniem Jordana-Wignera, żeby śledzić
antysymetrię i zapewnić, że właściwe statystyki całego układu fermionowego są przestrzegane. Odwzorowanie
Jordana-Wignera jest konceptualnie proste ze względu na korelację jeden-do-jednego między orbitalami a qubitami. Istnieją
inne odwzorowania osiągające podobny cel, w tym odwzorowanie parzystości.
Obliczenie parzystości stanu wymaga uwzględnienia wielu qubitów. W odwzorowaniu parzystości i niektórych innych, interpretacja
jednego qubitu odpowiadającego jednemu orbitalowi nie obowiązuje.
Przejdźmy teraz przez dość prosty przykład razem, żeby upewnić się, że rozumiemy tę transformację. Powiedzmy, że
chcemy obliczyć jednoqbubitowe oddziaływanie f dagger f. Zaczynamy od wstawienia naszych definicji dla
operatorów podnoszenia i obniżania. Następnie możemy grupować człony, wyciągając macierz jednostkową i i 1/4.
Jak widzimy, pozostają nam człony, które będą znane tym, którzy zajmowali się relacjami komutacyjnymi. Ten człon tutaj w
nawiasie to nic innego niż i razy komutator x i y. I nie
zapomnij o macierzy jednostkowej, którą wyciągnęliśmy.
Pamiętaj, że to są po prostu macierze pauliowskie. Więc komutator jest dobrze znany. Komutator x i y w
tej kolejności jest prosty – to 2iz. Pilnuj, żebyś nie gubił śladów znaków ujemnych, i dostaniesz to jako końcowy
wynik. Na końcu udało nam się pomyślnie przepisać wyrażenie fermionowe
w kategoriach operatorów pauliowskich, które nasz komputer kwantowy będzie mógł zrozumieć.
Omówmy pokrótce, jak zaimplementowalibyśmy odwzorowanie Jordana-Wignera w Qiskit, bo choć myślę, że to ważne,
żeby rozumieć, jak to odwzorowanie i podobne transformacje działają i zobaczyć je przeprowadzone przynajmniej raz, to
nie chciałbyś ręcznie wykonywać wszystkich tych obliczeń za każdym razem.
Zwłaszcza dla układów o dużym rozmiarze możemy korzystać z funkcji sparse poly op w Qiskit, żeby
łatwo tworzyć powiązane operacje pauliowskie z odwzorowania. Nieoptymalna
implementacja używa zagnieżdżonych pętli i zajmuje około 20 linii kodu.
Podam tu link do kodu dla was do zbadania. Ale na wysokim poziomie kroki są następujące.
Pierwszy: użyj funkcji sparse poly ops from list, żeby stworzyć operator jednostkowy
odpowiadający rozmiarowi mapowanej przestrzeni parametrów. Drugi: zgodnie z definicją operatorów kreacji
i anihilacji pokazaną wcześniej, użyj funkcji sparse polyops from list, żeby zdefiniować operacje pauliowskie x, y i z.
To zmapuje fermionowe operatory kreacji i anihilacji na operatory spinowe qubitów, kodując fermionową liczbę obsadzenia
w bazie obliczeniowej qubitów. I trzeci: wygeneruj pożądany
Hamiltonian w bazie pauliowskiej, stosując powyższe operatory do badanych orbitali. Zazwyczaj odpowiada to
tworzeniu macierzy jednostkowej, która reprezentuje rdzeń – nieoddziałujące orbitale – a następnie stosowaniu operatorów kreacji
i anihilacji do przestrzeni aktywnej z wagami odpowiadającymi specyfice rozważanego problemu. Jak
wspomniałam, to jest tylko ogólny zarys. Kod nie jest jednak zbyt skomplikowany i powinieneś teraz
czuć się pewnie adaptując go do innych problemów, które cię interesują.
Teraz, gdy w pełni rozumiemy schemat odwzorowania Jordana-Wignera, zobaczmy go w działaniu w bardziej skomplikowanej konfiguracji. Możesz
pamiętać ten artykuł z poprzedniego odcinka o dynamice hadronowej. Nie będę ponownie szczegółowo omawiać artykułu, ale sprawdź
poprzedni odcinek, jeśli go przeoczyłeś i jesteś ciekawy. W tym przykładzie odwzorowanie Jordana-Wignera jest używane do
wyrażenia Hamiltonianu węzłów siatki z L węzłami dla modelu Schwingera przy braku pola elektrycznego. Tutaj
trudniej jest konkretnie określić, co representuje jeden qubit w tym modelu, bo to tylko
zbiór qubitów razem tworzy coś fizycznego – w tym kontekście pakiet fal. Zamiast tego, możesz z grubsza
myśleć o qubitach jako zdyskretyzowanych kawałkach przestrzeni, gdzie tutaj L to objętość siatki, w której każdy element lub
komórka jednostkowa składa się z dwóch qubitów. Operatory fermionowe, które widzieliśmy na poprzednim slajdzie, opisują amplitudę
funkcji falowej w konkretnym miejscu.
Więc nasz Hamiltonian zawiera te fermionowe operatory podnoszenia i obniżania. Ale żeby zaimplementować taki
Hamiltonian na komputerze kwantowym, będziemy musieli wyrazić go w kategoriach operatorów spinowych, a nie fermionowych.
Więc używamy transformacji Jordana-Wignera. Po zastosowaniu transformacji Jordana-Wignera nasz nowy
Hamiltonian staje się tym równaniem na dole slajdu, gdzie sigma plus to operator pauliowski X + iY i sigma
minus to X - iY. Gdy mamy Hamiltonian zapisany w tym formacie,
trudna część etapu mapowania jest skończona i można go teraz łatwo zapisać do circuit w operatorach pauliowskich.
Podsumowując, omówiliśmy cztery przykłady tego, jak konkretne techniki mapowania były niedawno używane w
dziedzinie obliczeń kwantowych. Zaczynając od najprostszego i dochodząc do zastosowania transformacji Jordana-Wignera do
dynamiki hadronowej. Zdaję sobie sprawę, że to dużo. Ten materiał był bardzo techniczny
i jeśli wcześniej go nie widziałeś, może być bardzo onieśmielający. Dobra wiadomość jest taka, że obiecuję, że będzie łatwiej i bardziej
znajomo, im więcej czasu spędzisz ćwicząc. I to jest właśnie sens tej gry i dlatego nazwałam całą
serię „Obliczenia kwantowe w praktyce".
To nie jest coś, co ktokolwiek może po prostu podchwycić i od razu z tym biegać. Wymaga to trochę nauki, trochę
drapania się po głowie i prawdopodobnie kilku frustrujących momentów. Ale zachęcam was wszystkich, żebyście siedzieli z tym dyskomfortem i
naprawdę zgłębiali pytania, które pojawiają się w miarę kontynuowania, bo to jedyny sposób, żeby naprawdę się nauczyć. Dzięki za
oglądanie. To był odcinek 5 obliczeń kwantowych w praktyce. Następnym razem będziemy eksplorować, jak symulować
Hamiltonian od zera. Do zobaczenia wkrótce.